Guillaume eragne directeur de
l'Observatoire français des drogues et
des tendances addictives merci de votre
présence à cette audition devant notre
commission d'enquête sur l'impact du
narcotrafic en France et les mesures à
prendre pour y remédier on va commencer
par vous demander de présenter la
personne qui vous accompagne et puis on
aura la prestation de serment qui est
requise devant cette commission
d'enquête entendu merci monsieur le
Président donc je suis accompagné
d'Ivana Obradovic qui est directrice
adjointe de l'Observatoire français des
drogues et des tendances addictives et
qui est notre coordinatrice éditoriale
et scientifique à
l'OFDT merci beaucoup alors je rappelle
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête serait passible des
peines prévu aux articles 434-13 434-14
434-15 du code pénal et je vais vous
inviter tous les deux à prêterèement de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
à lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure je le
jure je le jure merci euh on vous
propose de commencer par un propos
limininaire puis ensuite Étienne blanc
notre rapporteur pilotera la séquence
des questions-réponses
entendu merci monsieur le Président
alors en propos liminire on voulait
peut-être vous dire un un mot très
succin de ce qu'est notre observatoire
observatoire français des drogues et des
tendances addictives donc on est un
groupement d'intérêt public qui a une
gouvernance interministérielle via une
via son Assemblée général avec un
collège scientifique indépendant qui
comprend une vingtaine de membres notre
équipe elle est plus prdisciplinaire
avec une unité chargée essentiellement
des études quantitatives et une unité
chargée plutôt des études qualitatives
on a comme mission l'observation des
drogues licites comme illicites ainsi
que des jeux de hasard et d'argent nos
travaux ils sont destinés à informer en
premier lieu les décideurs publics mais
aussi les professionnels du champ et
plus largement l'ensemble du grand
public intéressé par les questions des
drogues et des addictions on a une
mission qui est aussi celle d'être le
point focale nationale pour la France
auprès de l'Agence européenne des
drogues alors en propos liminaire on
voulait peut-être commencer par vous
rappeler quelles étaient les grandes
tendances durant ces dernières années
d'évolution des usages de substances en
population générale française alors nos
enquêtes en population générale auprès
des adolescents c'est-à-dire des
adolescents là à l'âge de 17 ans montrre
depuis les années à peu près 2010 une
tendance à la baisse de l'ensemble des
des des l'expériment mentation et des
niveaux d'usage de de substances c'est
vrai pour les substances licites mais
c'est vrai pour ce qui vous importe plus
particulièrement aussi pour les substan
illicite en ce qui concerne le le
cannabis juste à titre d'exemple à l'âge
de 17 ans l'usage l'usage du
cannabis au moins une fois par mois est
passé en 2011 autour de 22 % à 14 % à
peu près en 2000 en 2022 chez les jeunes
chez les jeunes de 17 ans cette tendance
P à à la baisse du niveau
d'expérimentation des drogues illicites
à 17 ans se retrouve aussi pour les
autres substances psychoactives
notamment pour la cocaïne par exemple
avec l'expérimentation à 17 ans qui
était autour de 3 % en 2011 et qui est
passé à 1,4 % en en 2022 alors c ces
tendan à la baisse des niveaux de
consommation on les retrouve aussi d'une
manière générale à l'âge adulte dans nos
enquêtes en population générale avec une
exception qui est celle des des
stimulants et en particulier de de la
cocaïne où là on observe plutôt une
augmentation des niveaux d'usage en
population en population adulte à titre
d'exemple vous avez pour la cocaïne
l'usage dans l'année qui était autour de
0,9 % en population générale française
adulte en 2010 et qui est passé en 2017
à 1,6 pour ça semble des des des
chiffres des pourcentages faibles mais
comme c'est rapporté à la population
générale adulte française ça correspond
à un nombre important bien sûr de de
personnes et les premiers résultats que
l'on a de notre enquête en population
générale en 2023 montre qu'on y rêve
quasi vers un vers un quasi doublement
un petit peu moins d'un doublement de
l'usage dans l'année de la cocaïne chez
les adultes en population générale
française en 2023 comparativement à
2017 alors cette cette augmentation de
de la prévalence de l'usage des des
stimulants et notamment de la cocaïne en
population générale française
s'accompagne d'une perception de la
dangerosité de la cocaïne qui a tendance
à diminuer dans la population générale
française et dans un de nos dispositifs
qui d'enquête permanent qui évalue les
représentations et les opinions
vis-à-vis des usages de substances on
observe par exemple que en 2008 6 % de
la population française a adul
considérit dangereux l'usage de cocaïne
à partir dès lors que la consommation
était quotidienne uniquement si la
consommation était devenue quotidienne
et ça cette cette ce pourcentage est
passé à 14 % en 2018 ça veut dire qu'on
on a une augmentation de la part des
gens qui considè que l'usage de cocaïne
n'est dangereux que à partir d'une
consommation quotidienne dans les autres
évolutions vis-à-vis des usages de
substances
illicites il y a une une tendance gén à
une augmentation de la de la pureté des
des des des produits qui sont qui sont
consommés par les utilisateurs c'est
vrai pour la résine de cannabis c'est
vrai pour l'herbe de cannabis c'est vrai
pour l'héroïne et c'est vrai pour la
cocaïne avec pour la cocaïne quand même
un fait particulièrement marqué en 2011
la teneur en cocaïne dans les dans les
les les échantillons qui était prélevé
était autour de 45 % et en 2020 elle est
passée à 63,5 % avec un prix qui lui n'a
pas beaucoup augmenté et cette tendance
là à une à une pureté qui de qui qui
s'améliore avec un prix qui reste quasi
stable on l'observe aussi comme je vous
le disais pour pour le cannabis et la et
la et et l'héroïne alors en terme de
marché euh ce qu'on observe c'est un
marché qui est globalement pour
l'ensemble des drogues illicites en
augmentation au niveau de l'Union
européenne avec les données de l'Agence
européenne des drogues en 2021 qui
montrait qu'en terme de nombre de saisis
on est à peu près à 1/3 de saisis qui
concerne l'herbe de cannabis 1/3 qui
concerne la résine 15 % qui concerne la
cocaïne et le craque et le et et le le
tout le reste des drogues illicites euh
dans le le pourcentage restant en terme
de de ces nombres de saisies et en terme
de quantité euh saisie en 2021 au sein
de l'Union européenne 2 ti3 concerernit
la résine de cannabis et à peu près à
par égal dans le tiers restant la
cocaïne et l'herbe de cannabis vis euh
les infractions qui résultent de de des
infractions la législation des
stupéfiants en Europe là encore c'est
des données de l'Agence européenne des
drogues de 2000 de 2021 montre quand
même que le que ces infractions
c'est très majoritairement des
infractions liées à l'usage évidemment
illicite par rapport au au au trafic
quatre fois plus de de de de nombre de
d'infractions recensées dans l'Union
européenne pour usage par rapport au au
au trafic et l'immense majorité de ces
infractions sont liées euh à à la à la
consommation à la détention de de de
cannabis 45e des des euh des des
infractions à la législation des
stupéfiants pour usage euh lorsque en
France il y a donc une infraction à la
législation des stupéfiants euh ce que
l'on observe dans la littérature c'est
une réponse pénale qui est vraiment euh
très généralisé euh plutôt sous la forme
de l'amende en ce qui concerne les des
usages de stupéfiants et plutôt sous la
forme d'emprisonnement à peu près à
moitié un surs total et à moitié pour
emprisonnement ferme ou partiel pour en
ce qui pour en ce qui concerne le
trafic je vais maintenant vous dire
quelques mots plus spécifiques sur la
question du cannabis alors les usages de
cannabis en population générale en
France on est quand même le le 4e pays
européen dans lequel la prévalence du de
l'usage du cannabis au cours du dernier
mois est la plus élevée et et donc on
est juste derrière donc l'Espagne la
tchquie le Pays-Bas et donc en 4e arrive
arrive la France en terme de demande de
soins dans les structures spécialisées
d'adidictologie médico-sociale que sont
les xapa on a à peu près 30 % de des
usagers qui rapportent un trouble de
l'usage du cannabis comme un des motifs
de leur consultation dans les centres de
soins addictologiques et c'est euh c'est
une c'est une une répartition en
fonction des produits consommés qui est
relativement stable au sein de la
philactive des des patients qui
consulent dans ces
structures là encore pour le cannabis
comme d'une manière générale pour
l'ensemble des des des substan illicite
on voit une augmentation quand même très
marquée de la teneur en en delta 9 THC
qui est le principal principe
actif en terme d'effet psychoactif dans
le dans le cannabis avec à titre
d'exemple pour la résine une
concentration en THC de 11 % dans les
années 2000 2010 et qui dans les années
2022 atteint 30 %. alors ça ça ça pose
unbre de problème en terme notamment de
de de conséquences de d'usage du
cannabis sur la santé publique parce que
évidemment les effets psychoactifs quand
on a des produits qui sont beaucoup plus
fortement concentrés sont sont pas les
mêmes et apparaissent des effets
indésirables qui sont nouveaux du fait
de cette teneur particulièrement élevé
en delta 9 THC dans les échantillons de
de cannabis consommés par les
utilisateurs en ce qui concerne les
modes d'approvisionnement il y a une
petite différence entre les usagers non
réguliers de cannabis qui déclarent dans
nos enquêtes ce ce provisionné quand
même majoritairement par le biais d'une
connaissance alors que quand ça devient
des utilisateurs réguliers là
apparaissent un peu à par égal des modes
d'approvisionnement que sont la
livraison à domicile le rendez-vous ou
la fréquentation d'un point deal voilà à
par égal pour ces trois types
d'approvisionnement chez les usagers
réguliers donc le marché du cannabis en
Europe c'est le marché illicite quiait
le plus qui est le de dans les données
que l'on a de l'Agence européenne des
drogues le plus grand marché de la
drogue dans l'Union européenne ça
correspond à peu près 11,4 milliards
d'euros par an et dans ce marché c'est à
peu près 2 ti3 l'herbe du cannabis et
1/3 1/3 pour pour la résine en terme de
saisie en 2021 au sein de l'Union
européenne les quantités d'herbes et de
résine ont atteint leur niveau de plus
élevé jamais recensé en terme de de
saisie la provenance donc la provenance
de la
résine elle est essentiellement
évidemment du en provenance du Maroc pas
produite sur le territoire de l'Union
Européenne en revanche le point d'entrée
très majoritairement dans l'Union
européenne c'est c'est via l'Espagne
bien sûr en ce qui concerne l'herbe en
revanche le la provenance là est un peu
différente avec une ma enfin même
extrême différente avec la majeure
partie de l'herbe qui est produite au
sein de l'Union européenne et environ 75
% de de cette de cette herbe est
produite en Espagne bien qu'il y ait
d'autres pays producteurs qui commencent
à émerger tels que les Balcans
voilà quelques mots maintenant
spécifiquement sur la cocaïne puisque je
vous disais que parmi les les évolutions
notables de dans les les niveaux de
consommation en population générale
française c'est notamment pour cette
substance qu'on observe une augmentation
des niveaux d'usage euh juste pour vous
le redire l'usage de la cocaïne dans
l'année on était en 2017 à 1,6 %
population générale adulte française
contre 0,9 % en 2010 et on va vers une
augmentation euh autour de 2,8 % à peu
près en 2023 par rapport à 2017 en
sachant que ce dernier chiffre pour 2023
comme il est très récent il il reste
encore à consolider sur le plan sur le
plan statistique donc ça se traduit ça
par des dommages en termees de santé
publique assez majeur avec une
augmentation très forte de la demande de
soins pour intoxication aigu à la
cocaïne ou sevrage à la à la de la
cocaïne dans les structure d'urgence
comme motif d'hospitalisation et comme
motif de fréquentation des structures
médicau-sociales
spécialisé avec une forte augmentation
notamment avant 2020 et puis ensuite qui
s'est stabilisé entre 2020 et 2021 du
recours aux soins addictologiques pour
usage de de cocaïne ou de crack à noter
qu'en terme de mode d'approvisionnement
pour la cocaïne on est peut-être sur une
des substances pour lesquelles
l'approvisionnement vient un point de
Deal physique et le et et le mode
d'approvisionnement le le moins
fréquemment déclaré par les utilisateurs
on est à moins d'un/art des utilisateur
de de cocaïne qui en 2021 rapportaiit ce
ce s'approvisionn sur un point de Deal
physique donc bien sûr comparativement à
d'autres modes
d'approvisionnement Internet les
livraisons à domicile les réseaux
sociaux alors d'où vient la cocaïne qui
circule en France c'est à peu près à par
égal peut-être un peu plus du Pérou que
de la Colombie mais c'est les deux pays
principalement d'où qui sont les les
principaux fournisseurs de la cocaïne
que l'on que l'on voit en France
circuler et les saisies en France elles
sont majoritairement comme vous le savez
même très très majoritairement 84 % des
saisis en 2021 se faisaent dans des
régions portuaires en fait c'est des
saisies maritimes avec en 2021
15,8 tonnes saisies dont
10,3 rien que sur le port du Havre donc
un des principaux points d'entrée de la
cocaïne sur notre territoire national
sur maintenant la question des des
opioïdes euh un petit euh un petit focus
sur les
opioïdes qui dont l'usage est quand même
largement généralisé au niveau mondial
avec 1,2 % de la population mondiale qui
en a déjà consommé euh un usage qui est
stable au niveau mondial après en 2021
après une légère augmentation euh entre
2017 et 2019 euh à noter que c'est les
drogues qui sont les plus meurtrières à
peu près 2 tiers des décès directs he
liés à l'usage de drogue
sont lié à des overdoses lié au au
consommation d'opioide il y a deux
épidémies en cours une épidémie bien sûr
de fintanil en Amérique du Nord et une
épidémie plutôt de de autour du tramadol
en Afrique du Nord et et de l'Ouest
alors concernant un opioïde qui était
qui est celui qui qui est le qui
classiquement était utilisé par les par
les personnes qui ont une dépendance aux
OP c'est l'héroïn on on observe depuis
2014 une tendance à une baisse des
modalités d'usage par injection de façon
assez sensible et en revanche des
modalités d'usage qui tournent plutôt
maintenant autour de la consommation
sous forme inhalée sous forme
fumée beaucoup plus que sous forme
injectée voilà et donc donc ça c'est des
tendances qui ont beaucoup changé et une
demande de soins qui est à peu près
stable autour de de l'héroïne à à peu
près 30 % des patients qui fréquentent
les structures médico-sociales
spécialisées en
addictologie rapportent un un un trouble
de l'usage des des opioïdes alors la
production
d'héroïnes évidemment plus de 80
% c'est provient de provient de la
culture de l'opium en Afghanistan
puisque l'héroï est un est un opioïde
semi-synthétique alors encore en en 2022
la production mondiale était autour de
de de de 7800 tonnes essentiellement
d'Afghanistan euh avec une route du
trafic qui empreunte majoritairement les
les les Balcans euh à noter donc deux
points de vigilance la première c'est
que euh le évidemment la la récolte
d'opium en 2023 en Afghanistan euh est
euh extrêmement euh euh compromise ce
qui fait que euh il y a des marchés
alternatifs qui peuvent émerger pour
l'instant on n pas de données sur ce qui
ce qui va pouvoir émerger de cette de ce
changement de de configuration dans le
marché mondial de de de
l'héroïne néanmoins on observe quand
même une augmente une forte augmentation
depuis 2021 des saisis d'opioïdes
pharmaceutiques au niveau mondial ça
c'est les données de de l'ONU décès 2
2023 la l'immense majorité des héroïnes
qui sont ensuite disponibles sur le
territoire national sont des héroïnes
coupées coupé avec des des des
adultérants c'est des agents qui de
coupe qui ont des propriété psychoactive
et c'est essentiellement de la caféine
et du paracétamol comme produit de coupe
avec quand même ça c'est les produit de
coupe classique certaines régions sur le
territoire national grâce à nos
dispositifs de de contribution à la
veille sanitaire à l'OFDT on on a montré
que de nouveaux produits de coupe
commençent à émerger dont notamment les
canamidoïde de synthèse et là les
usagers peuvent être effectivement
extrêmement pris au dépourvu et surpris
parce que c'est pas du tout du tout les
mêmes effets que ceux auxquels il
s'attendait et ça peut induire des des
des conséquences médicales aigues
particulièrement particulièrement sévère
avec des régions qui sont très
concernées par des fortes conc des
héroïnes fortement concentré comme comme
l'île-de-fance et et l'Alsace en 2022 de
enfin dans le le système d'alerte
sanitaire de l'Agence européenne des
drogues les l'ensemble des des nouveaux
opioïdes qui ont été
recensés ce concerne la classe des
nitazen donc s'il y avait peut-être une
classe part il fallit être
particulièrement
vigilant c'est c'est cette cette cette
classe de
d'opioïde les substances ensuite de type
nouveau produits de syè de type
amphétaminique alors en France c'est
l'amphétamine qui est le stimulant le le
synthétique le le plus répandu et alors
que c'est Plô alors que c'est la
méthamphétamine dans dans dans dans
plusieurs autres pays et alors là la
production de substances de type
amphétaminique pour le coup elle est
vraiment européenne et concentrée dans
dans de dans deux pays la Belgique le
Pays-Bas avec un précurseur qui est qui
est le qui est le BMK qui normalement
peut être utilisé dans l'industrie mais
qui en fait est souvent acheté de façon
euh comment dire illégal directement
pour fabriquer des substances
synthétiques de type amphétaminique la
demande de soins pour ces substances là
amphétaminiques a tendance à augmenter
un peu entre 2020 et 2021 dans les
structures spécialisées sur les autres
produits de synthèse on a
essentiellement des signau qui concerne
les psycadéliques parmi lesquels la
kétamine bien sûr les canabidomides de
synthèse dont je vous ai dit qu'elle
pouvait être aussi des produits de coupe
d'autres d'autres substances plus
classiques teles que l'héroï et les
catinones qui sont qui sont aussi des
substances des nouveaux produits de
synthèse que l'on que l'on repère de
façon de importante et en terme de de
demande de
soin c'est pour ce ces substances que je
vient de citer là qu'on en a observé une
demande la demande de soins la plus en
en augmentation dans les structures de
soins médicaux-socials spécialisés en
addictologie sur le territoire sur le
territoire français avec par exemple
dans la file active 2020 des usagers de
xapa euh en France 1,9 % qui
déclaraient consommer des catinon et
pour les nouveaux patients 2021 c'est
6,8 %. donc avec une une augmentation là
importante et peut-être un toute dernier
élément sur ces nouveaux produits de
synthèse en terme de modalité
d'approvisionnement c'est pour ce type
de substance que l'approvisionnement euh
via à distance c'est-à-dire via les
réseaux sociaux via Internet et via
également le Darknet est le plus
important par rapport aux autres types
de de substances illicites donc en
conclusion euh nous on constate
effectivement une abondance de l'offre
une tendance à la diversification des
produits une disponib ilité qui
s'accroit et des modalités
d'approvisionnement qui là aussi se se
diversifie se diversifie beaucoup avec
bien sûr des points de vigilance dont
l'expansion de l'usage de de la cocaïne
et et des stimulants en population
générale française ainsi que des que des
nouveaux produits de
synthèse merci beaucoup je laisse la
parole à notre rapporteur Étienne blanc
très bien merci monsieur le Président
comment comment
euh vous expliquez la diminution
et qui ce ser dans un chiffre de 23,9 %
à 9,1 % et d'élèves de 3e qui ont
expérimenté le cannabis comment est-ce
que vous expliquez cette diminution très
significative h et pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle ne s'applique pas euh à la
cocaïne alors euh oui merci monsieur le
rapporteur pour votre question euh
cette baisse on on l'a on les hypothèses
qu'on peut formuler pour l'expliciter
c'est que on observe quand même chez les
chez les jeunes
euh adolescents préadolescents jeunes
adultes une baisse de la diffusion
l'expérimentation pour l'ensemble des
substances alors évidemment comme on
partait de de de haut pour le pour le
cannabis cette cette diminution marque
une amplitude qui est particulièrement
visible mais d'une façon générale pour
les les substances licides comme
illicdes on observe une une tendance à
la baisse de la diffusion dans les
jeunes générations alors euh pour le
cannabis cette baisse est peut-être
particulièrement marquée du fait
justement de la baisse aussi de
l'expérimentation du tabagisme chez les
jeunes et comme c'est des consommations
qui sont très fortement corrélées euh ça
ça ça a forcément une une un impact sur
le l'expérimentation de du cannabis euh
on on a aussi pu constater dans des
études la plutôt qualitative une
tendance à à une diminution de
l'accessibilité perçue du cannabis par
les jeunes ils ils ont ils ont le quand
on les interroge ils décareent que ce
serait plus difficile pour eux
maintenant qu'avant que de se procurer
de du cannabis euh et enfin on constate
aussi une transformation dans les études
qualitatives de des modalités de
sociabilisation des jeunes qui tournent
peut-être moins niveau des usages de
substances et vers d'autres d'autres
formes de pratiqu que dont il faut
évaluer aussi la le les retombées en
termees de santé publique mais c'est un
petit peu les les éléments qu'on que
l'on a pour les éléments d'hypothèse
pour répondre à à ces à ces évolutions
que l'on observe
ouais ce sont des enfin c'est le
résultat de politique de prévention
selon vous
le les campagnes puissantes qui on on
été mené notamment dans dans les
collèges ont porté leurs
fruits alors c'est sûr qu'il y a des
campagnes qui il y a des dispositifs
dans les collèges notamment qui ont
montré leur efficacité dans la
prévention de l'entrée dans les dans les
usages de substances notamment les les
les dispositifs les interventionnels de
développement des compétences
psychosociales donc ça il y a eu des
études scientifiques qui ont montré
notamment le retard à l'âge
d'expérimentation chez les jeunes qui
ont bénéficié de ce type de de de
dispositif
ensuite les les études actuelles
permettent pas de mettre directement
d'imputer directement une ou plusieurs
causes à ces
évolutions probablement que ces causes
sont multifactorielles et et on a pas de
données scientifiques précises pour
répondre à votre
questionou alors je je reprends ma
question sur la cocaïne on a une
flambée de la
consommation comment selon vous peut-on
s'y prendre pour aboutir à un résultat
je dis pas identique à
celui de l'her de cannabis mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer comme
campagne pour sensibiliser sur les
dangers de la
cocaïne alors
[Musique]
on le est- que la littérature montre
c'est que ce qui les stratégies les plus
efficaces pour agir sur des changements
de comportement c'est la combinaison
d'action sur l'offre et sur la demande
euh votre question est beaucoup centrée
sur la la question de la la demande donc
je je sais que
notamment la la mildk finance des
campagnes de de
prévention qui ont pour objectif par
rapport à cette question de la
dangerosité perçue de la cocane qui a
tendance à s'éroder dans la population
générale française à rappeler que des
usages même
ponctuels peuvent aboutir à des
conséquences graves y compris l'étal
euh ensuite
euh le les campagnes de prévention ell
effectivement elles doivent être assez
systématisées et en même temps aussi
euh se focaliser sur les publics plus
vulnérables euh donc
ça
nécessite d'agir à différents à
différents niveaux niveau populationnel
et au niveau de sous-groupe plus à
risque ouais
oui est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire
vos collaborations avec les services de
police et de justice qu'est-ce que vous
le rapporter réellement
h si si vous en êtes d'accord je vais je
vais
je vais laisser pour répondre à cette
question ivanaradovit une directrice
adjoint de vous répondre oui alors déjà
la la première modalité de collaboration
c'est que le les ministères de
l'Intérieur et de la justice sont
membres de du Jeep donc qui participent
à notre assemblée général et et sont
régulièrement informés de notre
programme de travail et peuvent aussi
éventuellement nous solliciter sur sur
des études particulières euh on
travaille ensuite avec les les services
du ministre minre de l'Intérieur en
particulier
l'ofast du point de vue de la
transmission de
données également les les laboratoire de
police scientifiqu qui sont rattachés au
SNPs donc il y en a C aujourd'hui à
l'île Marseille Paris Rennes et Lyon
euh on est également en lien avec les
services statistiques des ministères à
la fois de l'Intérieur et de la justice
ce qui nous permet de suivre l'évolution
par exemple des interpellations ou de la
la réponse pénale et puis euh dernier
point mais mais pas le moins important
dans le cadre de nos dispositif de
remontée d'information qualitative qui
s'appelle trend tendance récente et
nouvelles drogue où on s'appuie sur neu
coordinations régionales qui enquêteent
auprès de sous-population d'usager
c'est-à-dire vraiment les les publics
les plus consommateurs de produits ce
qu'on trouve soit dans ce qu'on appelle
les espaces urbains c'est c'est-à-dire
les squat la rue les les les centres
d'accueil
basseuil et puis également ce qu'on
appelle l'espace festif c'est-à-dire les
rêves les technivales et cetera dans ces
espaces là de
consommation on a à la fois des
remontées d'information qualitativ
c'est-à-dire des observateurs qui sont
présents physiquement et qui qui
remontent des des données sur les
comportements des consommateurs les
types de produits qui circulent les
manières de les consommer mais et on a
également de la collecte de produits
qu'on fait analyser en en lien avec les
laboratoires de de police scientifique
précisément euh et également un
laboratoire du du CHU de Lille donc
voilà et dans le cadre de ce dispositif
trade on organise des ce qu'on appelle
des focus group c'est-à-dire des
entretiens collectifs avec l'ensemble
des acteurs locaux de l'application de
la loi donc dans les préfectures les
services de police et cetera avec l'idée
d'échanger autour des dynamiques
de circulation des produits et d'avoir
un diagnostic territorial qui est
actualisé chaque année et qu'on peut
comparer ensuite d'un site à l'autre à
travers les différentes
métropoles Michel Masset
oui en complément la première question
de monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces jeunes c'est quel
public quel
tranch parties social qui sont
principalement touché est-ce qu'elle
évolu ou pas en
fait on va prendre une question aussi
d'Olivier kadiic pour compléter
oui j'avais une question par rapport aux
jeunes est-ce que la aussi est-ce que la
baisse constaté chez les jeunes en
France dont vous nous avez fait part
s'observe également dans d'autres pays
en Europe et la ma question aussi c'est
un peu pour parce que chiffre donné
isolément n'a pas forcément une grande
enfin perd un peu de sa consistance
quels sont les pays qui ont les
meilleurs résultats en matière de de
baisse de d'utilisation de drogue
actuellement merci et j'y j'y ajoute une
question trè très ouverte vous avez un
collège
scientifique quels sont les sujets
qui qui font débat ou
qui traversent un peu vos réflexions
parce que là vous nous avez apporté une
vision très STATIS très froide des des
des produits des consommations des
évolutions est-ce qu'il y a des sujets
qui sont clivant des des sujets qui sont
des sujets d'intérêt d'inquiétude et
donc vous dites tiens c'est c'est
làdessus qu'il faut qu'on focalise nos
nos
réflexions si vous le voulez bien je
vais d'abord répondre à votre question
et puis ensuite ma collègue va répondre
aux questions précédentes euh oui notre
collège scientifique il a effectivement
pour objectif de de de nous aider à à
élaborer notre programme de travail donc
notre programme de travail il vise à
donner des informations
effectivement scientifique de nature
statistique mais pas exclusivement aussi
de nature comme le disait madame
Obradovic de type ethnographique
sociologique médico-économique aussi
parfois pour l'analyse du coût social et
et c'est C ces analyses aussi de type de
de type veille sanitaire qui euh qui qui
qui ne peuvent nous orienter par sur les
les problématiques qui sont celles sur
lesquell on doit focaliser davantage
notre attention par
exemple quand on observe effectivement
une augmentation en population générale
de l'usage des stimulants nous on a
envie un peu en réponse à vos questions
de savoir qui ça concerne davantage
quels vont être les sous-groupes plus à
risque quand on observe des substances
nouvelles qui qui émergent les
canaminoïdes de synthèse quand on
observe des teneurs en produits qui qui
deviennent très élevés comme le les taux
très élevé en THC dans dans certains
échantillons de cannabis ça a abouti à
des nouvelles demandes de soins avec des
des symptômes cliniques qui sont qui
sont nouveaux donc c'est ça c'est ce
type de de de débat que nous avons c'est
comment on essaie de trouver des
stratégies innovantes pour euh tenir
compte et être en adéquation avec
l'évolution du marché des drogues et
l'évolution des US US AG dans les usages
qui qui sont pour en citer deux exemples
peut-être qui sont un peu nouveaux il y
a il y a dans les population notamment
migrante les les mesusages en
prégabaline qui sont pour lesqueles on
n' pas vraiment encore de protocole de
prise en charge de ces patients parce
que c'est des c'est des problématiques
qui qui sont
récentes
autre autre
exemple toutes les problématiques autour
des du kemsex c'est-à-dire de de l'usage
de substances dans un contexte texte de
de de de rapport sexuel qui qui là
implique tout un tas d'autres
problématiques très intriquées la santé
sexuelle les maladies sanctionement
transmissibles donc donc on essaie
d'observer ces phénomènes le plus
précisément possible pour pas nous
dresser directement des recommandations
de politique publique nous notre travail
il est d'essayer d'aider les décideurs
en fournissant des informations
scientifiques les plus précises et les
plus éclairantes possibles pour
qu'enuite les décideurs puissent
proposer leur
recommandations sur les évolutions de la
consommation chez les jeunes ailleurs en
Europe alors je vais parler surtout du
cannabis he puisque vous avez compris
que c'était le produit principal à
l'adolescence et que tous les autres
sont très marginaux même s'il y a une
certaine dynamique autour des des
stimulants ça reste quand même vraiment
très très très très
marginal globalement la tendance en
Europe Europe c'est c'est une baisse de
la consommation de cannabis chez les
jeunes avec quelques exceptions et
justement la France qui se classait il y
a encore quelques années vraiment en
tête du tableau européen du point de vue
de la consommation de cannabis chez les
jeunes est en train de perdre sa place
entre guillemets de de tête de liste
puisque ça augmente dans d'autres pays
par exemple en Espagne ou en république
tchèck euh et donc la France qui était
un niveau historiquement élevé à plutôt
une baisse de sa consommation euh ce qui
la rapproche finalement de la moyenne
européenne alors que dans d'autres pays
ça ça augmente et du côté de la cocaïne
euh il y a une une baisse quand même
caractérisée chez les adolescents
français à 17 ans d'après les toutes
dernières données de 2022 ce qui n'est
pas le cas dans tous les autres pays
européens donc ça c'est quand même une
une spécificité intéressante et sur la
question qui portait sur le la
stratification sociale des jeunes euh on
voit quand même que malgré cette baisse
de la consommation de cannabis qui est
réelle depuis 2014 donc c'est pas
uniquement un effet covid et une
réduction des sociabilités qui aurait
euh empêché les jeunes d'entrer en
consommation en quelque sorte euh il y a
une baisse globale mais avec un gradient
social qui reste très important
c'est-à-dire que les jeunes à 17 ans qui
sont descolarisé euh par rapport à des
élèves de filière générale sont beaucoup
plus consommateurs de la même manière
les les apprentis ou les élèves en
filière professionnelle sont beaucoup
plus consommateurs que les élèves de de
filière générale donc cette dimension
sociale elle est essentielle et quand on
regarde le noyau des usagers
problématiques de cannabis à 17 ans
qu'on repère avec un certain nombre de
de critères et de questions sur
lesquelles on pourra revenir si vous le
souhaitez on s'aperçoit que ce ce noyau
dur d'usager problématique là aussi
socialement euh et est plus défavorisé
que l'ensemble des des usagers le
deuxième point c'est que ça on le voit à
travers un certain nombre d'études
scientifiques là la capacité à sortir de
la consommation de cannabis à
l'adolescence
elle est elle est favorisé par le milieu
social c'est-à-dire que sans doute on a
plus de filets sociaux en quelque sorte
quand il y a une supervision parentale
importante quand on est dans un
établissement scolaire où l'encadrement
est est plus important euh et donc
évidemment les il y a une perte de
chance pour l'avenir du fait de la
consommation
importante de cannabis à l'adolescence
qui qui est majoré dans dans les milieux
sociaux les plus
défavorisés d'res questions chez les
collègues on évoquait tout à l'heure
dans une audition
précédente efficacité euh de la
légalisation du cannabis en terme de
d'impact sur les trafics dans la mesure
où plus personne n'était monooduit était
multiproduit est-ce que vous vous avez
une approche différenciée en terme de
communication ou est-ce que euh toutes
les drogues même combat est-ce qu'il y a
des spécificité de communication eu
égard au au public que vous avez
évoqué alors sur la légalisation du
cannabis on on suit les évolutions
internationales de très près euh vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui en Europe aucun
pays n'a légalisé euh si ce n'est Malte
par une loi de décembre 2021 mais qui
légalise non pas en en ouvrant un marché
commercial mais en autorisant la culture
à domicile dans la limite de quelques
planans et avec des cannabis Social Club
comme on les appelle c'est-à-dire des
sortes de coopératives de consommateurs
mais il y a pas de boutique euh où on
peut accéder à du cannabis comme en
Amérique du Nord c'est-à-dire euh dans
23 États sur 50 aux États-Unis et dans
l'ensemble du Canada alors ce qu'on peut
voir déjà il faut préciser que on a un
recul qui est encore limité sur ces
expériences puisqu'on on a même pas 10
ans de de retour d'expérience donc ça
c'est la première chose ce qu'on voit
pour le moment c'est que les les
modèles libéraux business friendly
pourrait-on dire qui sont développés aux
États-Unis ont sont allés de Perre avec
un développement économique très
important et que la santé publique a a
été très peu au centre de ces
dispositifs de régulation euh donc dans
les les argumentaires
prégalisation l'argument de la santé
publique du contrôle du produit de la
protection des consommateurs était très
présent mais en pratique les politiques
de régulation ont un peu perdu de vue
cet objectif et les autorités de
régulation c'est intéressant de voir
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt des
administrations fiscales ou des
instances ad hoc et où où on a
finalement rarement des représentants de
la de la santé publique alors ce qu'on
peut voir en terme d'effet sur le marché
noir puisque c'était votre question
c'est que
euh personne ne pensait que la
légalisation irait de per avec un
assèchement immédiat du marché noir il y
a forcément un recul progressif qui est
attendu et donc la question c'est de
voir dans quelle mesure ce recul est
rapide ou très lent euh et on voit qu'il
y a différents facteurs qui font que le
recul est rapide ou lent ça dépend
vraiment du mode mod de régulation
d'abord c'est-à-dire qu'au Canada alors
on a tendance à dire la légalisation au
Canada mais ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
puisque selon les 13 provinces et
territoires au Canada les les modèles
qui sont mis en place sont très
différents et il y a pas grand-chose à
voir par exemple entre le modèle du
Québec où il y a un monopole publicque
sur la distribution et la vente de
cannabis et le modèle de l'Alberta par
exemple qui est très libéral et qui
ressemble beaucoup à ceux qui sont
développés aux États-Unis donc
évidemment les effets non plus sont pas
les mêmes sur sur le marché noir ce
qu'on voit en gros et on peut comparer
aussi avec un petit pays qui a légalisé
lui aussi qui a été le premier pays au
monde c'est l'Uruguay en 2013 et qui lui
justement ne ne prétendait pas du tout
tirer profit de la légalisation du
cannabis c'est-à-dire que le la quantité
de cannabis qui est produite légalement
était plafonnée à 10 tonnes euh et les
produits qui sont mis sur le marché ont
été plafonnés à 8 % de THC donc vous
voyez
és tout qui son reltiv par rapport à
qu'on trouve sur le marché européen et
la conséquence direct de ça ça a été que
le marché noir a été particulièrement
vigoureux après la légalisation en
Uruguay puisque les usagers les plus
réguliers ne trouvaient pas leur compte
dans l'offre légale donc ça c'est le
premier point après quand on regarde à
l'échelle du Canada en général parce
qu'aux États-Unis la situation est assez
fragmentée puisque certes la moitié des
états on légal mais ça reste interdit au
niveau fédéral donc ça pose toute une
série de problèmes sur lesquels on
pourra revenir si vous le souhaitez mais
en tout cas ce qu'on voit au Canada
c'est que le marché noir a a reculé de
manière assez substantielle quand même
même si il y a un nouveau type de marché
noir qui est alimenté par une offre
légale
qui qui repose sur une surproduction
dans les états où le cannabis a été
légalisé il y a une filière industrielle
qui s'est développée très rapidement
boom économique et donc le Canada comme
les États-Unis ont des quantités de
cannabis produites légalement qui sont
extrêmement importantes qui sont bien
au-delà de la demande locale mais qui ne
peuvent pas exporter puisque ça reste
classé comme stupéfiant euh donc voilà
cette offre légale alimente un marché
illégal et c'est finalement une nouvelle
modalité de de de rebond des des marchés
illicites du
cannabis
ouis selon vous le
pardon est-ce que c'est pas
effectivement quelque chose un peu
conforme avec ce qu'on observe avec
l'Espagne puisque vous disiez justement
que l'augmentation de la production sur
le de cannabis sur le sol européen
venait principalement d'Espagne donc
est-ce que c'est pas est-ce que c'est
pas lié à ça aussi euh alors
effectivement la seule différence c'est
que la la production en Espagne est
totalement illégale elle a elle est elle
est elle s'inscrit pas dans une filière
industrielle et et et manufacturée
puisque en Amérique du Nord c'est ça
c'est des
entreprises des entreprises enfin c'est
c'est une filière industrielle très
professionnalisé avec des serveurs
informatiques dignes de ceux de la NASA
une vidéosurveillance et euh et tout un
tout un appareil de production des
infrastructures et des nouvelles
technologies qui sont mobilisées donc
c'est en terme d'ampleur et de et
d'échelle on n'est pas tout à fait sur
sur les mêmes
dimensions selon vous le le marché de la
drogue il est piloté par l'œuf ou est-ce
qu'il est piloté par la
demande
alors on a combien de temps
pour non merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur pour votre
question
je je suis je suis pas
sûr que que la littérature permette de
de de dire si c'est l'un ou l'autre a
priori ce que l'on constate comme
souvent dans notre champ c'est la
rencontre entre l'offre et la demand
ande et donc c'est pour ça que la
réponse qui est observé comme étant la
plus efficace dans la littérature c'est
la combinaison d'action sur l'offre et
sur la demande donc finalement c'est une
façon peut-être indirecte de dire que
c'est l'un et l'autre qui qui qui qui
joue peut-être peut-être des éléments de
de compréhension sur la question de la
demande la demande vous AZ effectivement
des facteurs de vulnérabilité au fait de
de consommer des substances on n'est pas
tous égaux au fait de au risque de
consommer des substances il y a des
facteurs de vulnérabilité qui sont
exogènes qui viennent de l'extérieur de
l'environnement social socioculturel
socio-anthropologique qui peuvent même
pour jouer un rôle très important pour
certains dont les événements de vie
précoce et l'existence de de trauma
précooces de l'enfance dont on sait
qu'ils sont très vulnérabilisant pour le
risque ensuite à terme de développer des
troubles mentaux et et des usages de
substances mais vous avez aussi des
facteurs qui euh euh sont pas dépendants
de facteurs de vulnérabilité exogène ils
sont donc par opposition au facteurs
exogènees endogène notamment c'est des
facteurs de vulnérabilité d'ordre
génétique on n'est pas tous
génétiquement euh on n pas la même le
même risque de développer telle ou telle
pathologie et c'est vrai aussi ça pour
les conduites addictives donc euh si
vous agissez exclusivement par exemple
sur euh les facteurs euh
environnementaux euh ce qui est indisp
ens d'être faitin mais vous aurez de
toute façon des gens qui quand
l'accessibilité au produit est est
rendue facilité vont
être vont plus accrocher au produit
parce que ils ont des facteurs de
vulnérabilité endogène à cela donc c'est
pour ça que même en agissant du mieux
qu'on peut sur les facteurs
environnementaux la la réduction aussi
de l'accessibilité en terme de
dénormalisation aussi de prévention de
opérage précoce de traitement des
comorbidités ça permet aussi de réduire
euh les l'exposition aux personnes qui
pourrai être plus à risque y compris
pour des raisons qui leur sont propres
tout à fait endogènes de de de rentrer
dans un usage de substan
psychoactif je sais pas si
oui pour ajouter un mot là-dessus quand
on regarde les les évolutions dans les
niveaux de consommation euh on retrouve
quand même toujours deux facteurs de
ressort qui qui qui explique
l'amplification de la consommation c'est
d'abord l'accessibilité financière quand
le prix d'un produit baisse logiquement
euh il a tendance à à progresser en
terme de de consommation et
l'accessibilité physique c'est-à-dire la
la la la représentation qu'on peut avoir
de la facilité à s'approvisionner euh on
le voit bien puisque dans les enquêtes
qu'on mène auprès des adolescents on
voit que euh pour euh pour beaucoup
d'entre eux 40 % à peu près de mémoire
euh ils savent exactement comment se
procurer du cannabis bien qu'il soit
illégal euh donc bon c'est c'est c'est
un facteur qui joue beaucoup et il y a
également les les représentations de des
risques euh lié au produit euh
c'est-à-dire l'image sociale en quelque
sorte euh qu'il a encore euh euh
contribue à expliquer l'augmentation de
de la
consommation sur cette question euh
quand on regarde comment notamment dans
les milieux urbains s'organise le trafic
euh la commercialisation de produits
stupéfiants on peut quand même imaginer
que les réseaux euh de trafiquants
organise tout cela dans un écosystème
et qui est qui qui permet de capter des
consommateurs hein ne serait-ce que la
présence des points d'î à des endroits
stratégiques euh pour aller chercher une
clientèle de jeunes enfin je veux dire
dans dans les villes la proximité des
points de d' avec les lycées avec les
collèges il y a bien une stratégie quand
même qui là c'est pour ça que je posé
cette question sur l'offre et sur la et
sur la demande et je pense moi que cette
offre elle est très largement organisée
par les réseaux pour accroître la
consommation notamment la consommation
de cannabis qui est une Dr qui dans la
proximité se commercialise avec une
facilité
déconcertante
euh oui bah effectivement euh
le cet écosystème dont vous parlez il a
pour
objectif une rentabilité économique donc
effectivement il mett en œuvre des
stratégies qui leur permettent de faire
le plus de profit possible et on observe
d'ailleurs dans les enquêtes qualitative
dans le cadre notamment du dispositif
train que vous avez mentionné dans vos
questions euh une généralisation
maintenant des euh des des offres de
type soldes prix prix
bradé campagne un peu de de de publicité
très euh très axé sur les jeunes
consommateur donc euh évidemment leur
les stratégies mises en place par
l'offre enfin utilise aussi les
stratégies habituelles que l'on observe
dans le euh
dans le marketing ou le ou leou la
publicité telle qu'elle telle qu'elle
telle qu'elle peut fonctionner pour
attirer les clients absolument
ouais dernière dernière question pour
moi
euh est-ce qu'on peut se donner un
objectif d'éradication de la
consommation de drogue est-ce qu'il
existe excusez la grossièreté du propos
euh un optimum de consommation et un
taux de chômage résiduel un taux de
consommation résiduelle dans une société
donnée est-ce que c'est des sujets qui
sont totalement délirants ou est-ce que
ça conceptuellement ça ça ça
existe alors c'est une question vraiment
vraiment difficile merci monsieur le
Président le en fait il y a il y a déjà
pour
certaines substance une des repères de
consommation alors effectivement là on
n'est pas sur les substances illicites
on est plutôt sur l'alcool que santé
publique France
a a actualisé en
2017 et en dessous de ces repères de
consommation on estime que les risques
que vous prenez pour votre santé à
consommer des risques individuels sont
des
risques tolérables accept au regard des
autres risques de la vie courante et au
regard de la place socioculturelle que
l'on accorde à cet usage de substance
donc donc il y a beaucoup de précautions
à prendre parce que effectivement ce
qu'on tolère comme un risque
acceptable c'est ce que le c'est
dépendant des autres risques de la vie
courante et dépendant de ce qu'une
société est prête à accepter comme
risque qu'un individu peut prendre en
ayant tel ou tel comportement donc je
désolé mais pas plus de réponse plus
précise que ça ouais ben peut-être pour
compléter d'un petit mot historiquement
il y a pas eu de société sans drogue
c'est-à-dire que même dans les états où
c'est totalement interdit
euh si ce n'est des stupéfiant ça sera
des des des produits détournés de leur
usage qui vont être utilisés ça peut
être des médicaments légalement
accessibles ça peut être des solvants
industriels toutes sortes de produits
des coles par
exemple donc ça c'est c'est la première
chose et et il faut rappeler d'une
certaine manière enfin avec beaucoup de
guillemets la fonction sociale des
drogues qui qui apaise la douleur qui
qui sont utilisés pour se relaxer pour
gérer d'une certaine manière une une
problématique individuelle ou parfois
sociale donc voilà c'est une dimension
qu'on peut pas totalement ignorer pour
prendre en compte le le phénomène le
deuxième point c'est même l'obj de 0 %
n'a jamais vraiment été affiché en tant
que tel je crois dans les sociétés
démocratiques en tout cas quand on
regarde le le le tabac il y a l'objectif
actuellement de la première génération
de non fumeurs en 2032 et l'objectif a
été fixé à 5 % de fumeur en population
générale donc l'éradication totale
semble relativement difficile à
atteindre et et peut-être même
chimérrique
je ne sais pas c'est pas à nous de le
dire ben si je peux juste terminer
compléter merci beaucoup oui peut-être
pour réinsister sur un élément qu'on
avait mentionné précédemment sur les
questions des facteurs de vulnérabilité
le poids des facteurs de vulnérabilité
au fait de de développer un usage de
substance à l'âge adulte est tellement
important ce qui concerne les facteurs
de vulnérabilité lié à l'enfance et à la
petite enfance que tout ce qui peut
aller dans le sens de de de la
protection de la jeunesse de la
protection vis-à-vis des traumas
infantiles des traumas des traumas de
l'enfance du développement des
compétences psychosociales dans une
objectif qui serait vraiment de de de de
réduire un maximum les risques au niveau
populationnel que de développer des
usages de substances et des conduites
addictives à l'âge adulte c'est un axe
euh fort au sens qu'il est
particulièrement bien documenté dans la
littérature dans la littérature
scientifique l'autre axe don on a pas
vraiment parlé peut-être c'est la
question aussi de du traitement des
comorbidités quand vous avez une
pathologie une autre pathologie mentale
quand vous avez une pathologie enfin
organique de type qui engregentre des
douleurs chroniques par exemple
forcément vous allezê beaucoup plus à
risque de vouloir un peu vous
automédiquer vous soulager avec des
usages de substances donc la prise en
charge euh précoce de des des
différentes des différents en trouble
physique comme psychique c'est aussi un
levier d'action qui peut être qui peut
être important est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
scientifiquement on peut
mesurer le rôle du
cannabis dans une progression de l'usage
de stupéfiant vers des drogues plus
dures on consomme d'abord du cannabis on
augmente ensuite les taux de THC bien
compris le risque il est un peu là et
puis quand le taux de THC est élevé le
passage à la cocaïne et à aux opiacé
est à mon est-ce que ça scientifiquement
ça a été
mesuré parce que pardon ça peut être
assez encourageant de constater
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une diminution
chez les adolescents
euh de
consommation de cannabis on peut se dire
il y aura moins de jeunes qui passeront
à la cocaïne qui pour m'exprimer
clairement
oui alors c'est vrai que on
on euh en même temps vous avez enfin la
littérature soutient le fait que plus on
a une une consommation de substances
psychoactive régulière plus on est à
risque d'en développer d'autres et et
effectivement ce que vous dites c'est la
question aussi un peu de de la
coagrégation des phénomènes addictifs
chez un même individu pas forcément en
terme de temporalité mais plutôt en
terme de de d'augmentation de la
vulnérabilité au fait d'avoir encore un
autre usage de substance parce que les
usages de substances quand ils
engendrent notamment une une dépendance
euh
on il il dérégulent un peu le le le
fonctionnement cérébral et ces
dérégulations là sont en soi des
facteurs de vulnérabilité au fait de
développer d'autres conduites addictives
et puis on peut avoir aussi tendance à
vouloir automédiquer des symptômes de
sevrage d'une substance avec une autre
donc vous voyez il y a des phénomènes
comme ça d'intrication entre les usages
qui sont très fort en revanche on
raisonne pas trop en terme de passage
d'une drogue moins dure à une drogue
plus dure euh parce que euh euh
on la question est est est pas vraiment
de d'essayer de quantifier la
dangerosité en valeur absolue d'une
substance par rapport à une autre euh
puisque les conséquences individuelles
du trouble de l'usage de cannabis
peuvent en soi être déjà tellement
dommageables qu'il y a pas besoin de
d'aller consommer d'autres sub substance
euh
donc effectivement ça ça plaide en
faveur d'une d'un repérage le plus
précoce possible des usages à risque
pour éviter qu'ensuite on se retrouve
avec des des des phénomènes de
polyconsommation de comorbidité en terme
de de trouble psychiatrique associés qui
qui vont rendre beaucoup plus difficile
ensuite forcément la la la prise en
charge des des des personnes
consommatrices
y a-t-il encore des questions pour
l'OFDT ses représentants non écoutez on
va vous remercier très chaleureusement
de votre présence et la qualité de vos
réponses et puis on sera heureux de les
lire par écrit en réponse au
questionnair qu'on vous a transmis merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le
rapporteur
y